no point worrying about if other people
like you because most people don't even
like themselves bro
welcome back to the three Muslims
without further Ado let's go into it
we are in the presence of a cultural
icon a physical specimen a
controversialist
a master orator
a champ
and we've also got Andrew take
that was smooth I like that I'll sit in
there thinking I'll take this
introduction I'll take this but uh thank
you how are you doing man I'm good to
you you're good yeah
congratulations thank you my friend you
know the the Muslim Community really
welcomes you man yeah it's been pretty
divided we've had a I've had a whole
bunch of support yes obviously there's
been some people who are not quite
pleased about the idea I think when you
have a passionate subject and people
that are truly engulfed in an idea
you're going to have some degree of
polarization I think that maybe when you
look in the online space that might be
your impression but in reality on the
ground I mean that's definitely not the
case I would say the vast majority of
people 80 90
are completely happy about this and it's
just it's just that the minority have a
very loud voice well that's exactly it
that's the whole problem with the
internet as a whole not just Islam but
the internet as a whole is about vocal
minorities
that look look much larger than they are
right yeah and I agree with you and I
I'd like to I'd like to hear that but
the reason I know what you're saying is
true is because it's the same even in my
case in other subjects online I have all
this some kind of hate or people trying
to disagree with me but when I walk
through life I have 30 000 interactions
with people not a single one's ever been
negative ever so it's it is crazy how
the vocal minority is Amplified on the
main thing to note though is that Islam
it completely wipes away your sins I
mean most of the companions of the
Prophet had done many things which are
genius and polytheism and I mean for us
as Muslims politicism is the worst thing
you can do yeah and so there is
states that Islam it completely
destroys everything before it means it
wipes away everything before it in other
words your slate is absolutely clean now
if there are some people who are
actually coming and giving you a bit of
a hard time that's actually their
problem yeah because in reality honestly
bro this is complete Islamic I mean so
that's that's the first thing it's
actually a verse in the Quran
interestingly interestingly enough as
well which says that
if you become a Muslim and
whoever repents and believes and does
good works
then God with will you bet did Allahu
say yes that God will change their bad
deeds into Good Deeds
so every how does that make you feel
well yeah that's obviously fantastic to
hear and good to know and um it's it's
interesting because I've I've spent very
little attention very little time paying
attention to the negative comments
because I I don't in general but on this
particular subject a few people were
forwarding me like the profiles of
somebody or of the people who were
unhappy with my conversion and they
weren't living very Islamic lives
themselves so it's kind of it's kind of
funny to look at you know
foreign
[Music]
I'm very happy for him man he looks very
happy and even the way he's conducting
himself on the podcast is very very
respectful alhamdulillah it's like it's
it's like he realizes and this is a good
thing for anyone who had concerns it
seems to be the case that he realizes
Islam is something big it's important
it's something he's new to so he can't
just come putting his own opinion here
and there and and I think he mentioned
somewhere in the podcast later I think I
saw a clip of him saying I'm here to
learn on Tick Tock or something so
that's about Islam then alhamdulillah
yeah that clip was basically saying that
he he knows you know one of the things
really like barricading him from
converting to Islam was the sheer amount
of work that he has to do you know I'm
sure on her bro after you know as you're
a river yourself after coming to Islam
you're probably just like bro there's
this then there's this then I gotta do
this like it is a lot because this is
one of those very few religions where
it's not just believe and you should be
saved you know
yeah if I would have known how much work
was like had to be done like before
going in I don't know I feel like that
would have kind of put me off but again
like I just I kind of jumped in and here
we are I did want to speak about this
point yeah I want to speak about this
point that Andrew Tate was saying and
how like people on the online just feel
like they're very entitled to their
opinion
and they just say what they want and
it's it's a very heavy voice but then
it's like when it's in person no one
says anything and this is like the
equivalent of like a keyboard Warrior
you know and like I've seen so much of
this in my own YouTube channel and then
um even on here on the t3n I've seen
people leave like some nasty comments
but it's like in real life
never never have I ever feel like I'm
playing this game never have I ever but
never have I ever had someone come up to
me and say something disrespectful to my
face
never it's only on the online sphere
where people would think to themselves
like ah you know what my opinion is
valid and I'm gonna say this because
well
I'm I'm more important than you so if I
say this then everyone should listen to
me it's just it's kind of ridiculous
yeah no one cares bro there's no point
worrying about if other people like you
because most people don't even like
themselves bro
that's deep
yeah 100 and um as someone who's gotten
a fair amount of heat online
alhamdulillah I've realized that Yani at
the end of the day
and this actually something somebody
told me after a video I posted that was
you know people some people didn't like
they said listen
a lot of the time the people who are
most willing to speak up are the ones
who have something negative to say
the people like people and think about
the time in your life where you felt
extremely happy but you didn't like you
know emphasize or Express how happy you
were you just felt the happiness you
were just almost most of the times I
don't post it most people don't post
good things no yeah yeah and now imagine
you know whenever like for example when
we were reading some of the tweets that
some of the people made about Andrew
Tate we're like we need to like you know
put these people on blast that's the
initial reaction most people have the
feeling of I need to like XYZ
that's that's what kind of a negative
response does to a person they want to
speak out and online creates this kind
of sphere and I think he realized this
which is why you're seeing a lot of like
in-person face-to-face podcasts he's
realizing online or virtual or like not
face to face increases the likelihood of
being disrespected of being cut off of
being clipped and edited and all these
crazy things uh because what are you
gonna do on the other end right you see
that's why I see a lot of people untick
talk themselves they'll be so firm in
whatever they're saying and rather than
you know going back on what they say and
say that okay actually what I said was
wrong they'll still have that opinion
but they'll take the video down because
they just can't take you know whatever's
coming at them because what they put out
was very negative to begin with you know
there are a few sisters I've seen that
actually went back and said okay my
reaction was a bit extra
but others you know may Allah make it
easy for them I've heard stories of
people really succumbing to the hate uh
developing you know suicidal thoughts
and and mental problems and being on
suicide watch so um mail I'll make it
easy for her
you know bro you just mentioned this
thing where it's like he's doing the
in-person podcast because there's like
less room for the the disrespect and it
reminds me of the the podcast I don't
know if it was a legitimate podcast or
something but he was doing it with this
one guy I'm pretty that's the guy the
dude just like flipped and he just
completely like started disrespecting
Andrew we made it in a way where it's
like let's get Andrew Ted on and then he
just used that and entitled it I made uh
Andrew Tate run away from a debate or
something like that something like was
it that one where he's basically saying
like oh Andrew Taylor you're always
going to be bald
um like you got you you can't even get
on YouTube like you you can't get on
anything I don't know about that yeah
I don't know but I think this is like a
guy who genuinely was like on like video
call with him and then he just I don't
know what like started disrespecting him
and I think it was like live I don't
know bro if I might be mistaken here but
like this is what like Romney was
reminding me of you where it's like in
person but it's just so different man
like what when we're when we're here
doing this video chat like you guys will
never do this to me I would never do
this to you guys because I love you guys
for the sake of Allah and just as
brothers right as like friends you know
like y'all we've been in each other's
lives for a minute now so but I wouldn't
disrespect you guys blaming me I
wouldn't like say something and put you
down like here especially here on like a
podcast
and then even more so in person why
would I do that why would I ever say
something like that and if I ever say
something I always like correct myself
because I know I'm wrong or you guys
correct me but even then like there's a
difference when it's in person versus
just virtual so I could see what
Romney's saying I was talking to one of
my clients in uh in New Jersey bro for
my fitness coaching and he just found
out how long we have known each other
bro
and for anyone that doesn't know it
hasn't even been two years since the
three of us have been friends this is
crazy bro when he found this out he was
like what I thought you guys were like
close for like 10 years 15 years 20
years I was like I've known Romney for
almost three years knowing on her for
almost three years but the three of us
collectively it hasn't even been two
years it's just closing in on two years
in like a few weeks
yeah and and the crazy part is it's not
really
like yeah we have our common traits but
it's not really about us it's about
Islam that's like I have people I've
I've known for like uh you know a lot
less time than I've known you guys and I
feel like this is my brother you know so
a person I I spoke to a few times only
met once recently because they came from
a different country I'm like this is my
brother you know that's just what Iman
does to you Russell said um
you know where the Prophet son talks
about you know they will uh basically
um
what's the Hadith uh something about a
Believer loves for his brother what he
loves for himself and many other none of
you will really believe until you love
for your brother what you love for
yourself yeah yeah
many a Hadith similar to that many I
asked in the Quran talking about the uh
you know indeed the Believers are about
brothers
when you have beliefs like that you
can't really look at a Muslim and be
like
you know abundance guy I don't like this
guy
with that being said insha Allah stay
tuned for the next video that we do
reacting to Andrew Tate's Weaver's story
Romy do you think